citizens of the reject nation that's correct
you hear that that is me being sworn in
allowed to say such a virtuous thing to welcome
you in hello you lovelies the x-men are coming
and based off the direction that marvel has been
going and based on the comic runs they've been
utilizing i've got an idea of the shape the team
is going to take and i've got casting for each of
two different versions that's right this video
is gonna be a little different i'm gonna cast
double and we'll get to that in just a second
but before please do leave a like youtube likes
when we do that please hit that subscription
hit the bell so you know when more videos are
coming and please leave a comment below because
i've got more than just these x-men to cast
if you want to see me extend my casting to the
greater x-men universe i've got some more ideas
but we'll get to that in another video follow
me on tick-tock if you want to see more of my
fan casting more comic ideas more all sorts
of nerdy stuff let's get into it my x-men
so the reason this casting video is gonna
be a little different is i think they can go
two ways in the mcu especially with the events of
miss marvel they might have a younger cast maybe
people in their 20s aging into the x-men like
we had in the original movies or they could have
an older cast of the x-men we know and love
teaching future waves of students coming in
a la x factor so i'm gonna cast a 20's era x-men
as well as a mid-30s era experience you're gonna
get two cast for the price of one first let's
kick off with professor x now there's been a lot
of talk of giancarlo esposito especially this last
week and i think that's a great call because he is
very ominous while being loving there's something
very paternal about him which is important for
chuck but also there's an an ominous overtone
of potential duplicity and i think that's really
important to go from the leader of the x-men the
one that gathers the x-men to eventually becoming
apocalypse the fact that he's friends with magneto
we need a character to seem loving and nurturing
but also like he has a dark side so i don't
necessarily think it's going to be giancarlo
esposito but i think it'd be a good choice if
they go that way my pick for the older version of
the character would be either ed harris or ralph
fiennes we're going to bring up ralph finds again
in a little bit so let's lean ed harris on this
one ed harris has been known to carry that i can
be trusted but only so far i'm a very regal figure
i've got a lot of authority but you could see him
going a darker way now if they go a little bit
younger i would love to see someone that is in
the mcu already but only very briefly sterling
k brown deserves to be a leading man in the mcu
sterling k brown can play both very reserved
controlled calculated but also very emotional
outbursts of rage outbursts of sheer empathy and
and everything you need in xavier is in that man
i would personally love and i know he's in black
panther i know i know he's involved but i want to
see him get a leading man role i want sterling
k brown for my professor x now we've brought up
our xavier we gotta bring up our magneto i
do think that even though we've seen a lot of
these two characters on screen you don't have the
x-men without magneto i would personally have the
first film be based on the sentinels be based on
government oversight be based on the department of
damage control-esque things but you need your big
bad and you need to build to the brotherhood of
evil mutants you need to build all those things
that are foundational so you need magneto now i
if they go older with an older magneto really
want michael wincott i don't know if you guys
know that name but you might know him from the
crow you might know him from the recently released
nope this man's presence is incredible he is an
older actor but every time he's on screen you're
so captivated you're so interested and his voice
if he doesn't play doom he should play magneto
there's so much history behind this man there's
so much intrigue behind every one of his weathered
lines and i could see him be just as interesting
to be followed as a leader as someone that you'd
be terrified of and that's very important
for the character magneto if you go younger
this is where we're bringing in ralph finds i
mentioned him for xavier which i do think is that
line of 70 good thirty percent concerning i wanna
see ralph finds in the in bruges sense i'd love to
see him in the more arrogant but with purpose like
i feel like magneto is arrogant but that's because
he knows he's the [__] and i think that's ralph
finds the man has bravado in his evil the man has
confidence a lot like michael fassbender does and
i'd really love to see that version of ralph finds
brought into the mcu he's my magneto now here's
where the age starts to make a difference those
actors are well established those characters well
established but when you bring in cyclops you need
to make sure they finally get cyclops right i love
james marston they didn't give james marsden a lot
of the script a lot of the action a lot of the
things you need for cyclops and he didn't have
the ability to emote a lot because he's got a
mask on you need a very strong actor here if
they go older if they go with a more professorial
someone leading as an already established x-men i
love justin hartley if you haven't seen this as us
he is absolutely incredible in that show he has a
lot of leadership ability he has a lot of charisma
he has a lot of ability to do a lot with a very
little amount the man can do a lot with his face
and that's important when it's half covered and
he's got that stoic rigid every man but want
to follow him into the trenches ness that is
very necessary now that is someone if the x-men
have been established if they're starting with
young x-men that we're gonna follow through dylan
o'brien man maze runners showed this guy can lead
a franchise major undershowed this guy is someone
you want to follow into battle maze runner showed
this guy is so charismatic that he gets people
to basically do what needs to be done in very
tricky situations and you want someone that jean
grey can fall in love with over wolverine harry
bob charm incarnate you need someone like dylan
o'brien and i think the way to do that is you cast
the leading man dylan o'brien's made to be cyclops
get it right he's a leader him in storm they gotta
lead the x-men they gotta be great speaking of
leaders of the x-men and in the comic runs i enjoy
in the 90s the jim lee era of x-men we're going
to talk about in the comic polls later there were
two teams there was the gold team and the blue
team and depending on how the movies go i could
see them splitting the giant team of x-men into
two different factions that might actually happen
and i would love to see storm be the leader of the
x-men as she is in the comics and you want someone
that's going to be right there alongside cyclops
or boston cyclops around you need that powerhouse
that i think dewanda weiss is if they have an
older storm i think dewanda weiss she was just
in the newest jurassic world to me she stole a lot
of the scenes she was in she has a presence about
her i would personally start with a storm solo
movie maybe even casting my young actress as the
flashbacks show her growing up in africa show her
being worshipped as a god show her claustrophobia
show her having to be a thief to make do and show
her evolving into the goddess of thunder that she
is this is the most cinematic character in the
x-men she's literally a roland emerick movie
come to life she controls the weather this
character deserves a full film or at least
the leader of the movie dwondaweis can carry
that very very strong weight on her shoulders
and if they go younger i would say alexis louder
if you haven't seen cop shop stole every scene cop
shop is an actor dream movie you've got gerard
butler and frank grillo acting their eyeballs
out at each other in a contained environment and
alexis louder debuted effectively in that film
and stole every scene she was in she looks
awesome with a bald head i want to see with
a white mohawk i want to see storm done in a way
that you want to not only have her lead the x-men
but you want to follow her into the world of black
panther you want to follow her into wherever they
bring that character next and you need either
one of these actresses to do it dwanda weiss
alexis louder i want to see them in that white
awesome flowing road so what is the x-men without
jean grey now don't you give me that phoenix sag
at first you earned the phoenix saga that's movie
nine you get there after three trilogies you don't
phoenix me again but on the way to that you need
to make sure this is a character that you want to
buy the love story of i want to see scott and gene
actually get to love each other give me some
notebook x-men action chris claremont one of
the most iconic ever writers of the x-men love
the soap opera elements of the x-men we need
more of that we need to believe these characters
before we put them in peril i want to love jean
grey if we go with an older actress someone in
their 30s i want rose leslie i loved her in game
of thrones i loved every moment we got with her i
love her presence in interviews she's someone that
i want to know more about and that's important
for jean you're in her head you're sharing a lot
of time with her you have empathy for her as she
gets destructive as things fall apart in her life
and she's so over powerful you need to have that
connection i think rose leslie definitely has that
if they go younger for growing up with jean grey i
would say either sophia lillis who we just had in
the it movies who is absolutely captivating you
care about her and peril already we've already
seen that and you care about her in the very boys
world dynamic the x-men it's a lot of dudes it's
called the x-men you want to make sure there's
someone that you're like wait what does she
want like what does she need in this scenario
and i think she'd be absolutely incredible
and then my other younger cast members jane levy
from shameless she is so interesting and she's so
able to hold her own amongst a family of heathens
like everyone in shameless is so much but every
time she's on screen you want to know more about
her and that's very important for jean grey those
are my three schnitz let's talk about wolverine
this is the one everyone's curious about this is
the one i think they should wait for to be honest
i included wolverine because he's wolverine but i
don't want this to become wolverine the x-men i
think that was what happened to the detriment of
the brian singer films is it became the wolverine
show and his buddies that's not what the x-men is
i would personally introduce wolverine the tv show
check out the video i made about that it's on this
very channel it's the first video we ever made of
koi's comments corner follow that journey but if
we are getting wolverine in this movie i would
like if he's older edgar ramirez edgar ramirez
has the physicality he seems like a guy that would
say bub i see him cigar chomping i see him as this
hairy mutant that's very feral if they can't
get tom hardy because he's venom i think edgar
ramirez has all of that energy and he seems like
a guy who's seen stream [__] and he can also do
his own stunts which i really respect if they go
younger this is the most tried and true answer but
there's a reason for it he's short he's stocky
he can act his eyeballs out he's buddies with
hugh jackman he can get the notes from him i think
taran edgerton should absolutely play the younger
wolverine what's tricky is is i see taran edgerton
maybe aging in the next five years 10 years
because he's like 30. that might be a tricky thing
for wolverine so age him up now that way as he
grows into the older terran edgerton we have an
established wolverine but i think taran edgerton
could absolutely slay it beast is a founding
member of the x-men and a very hard character
to get right i think nick holt absolutely slayed
it i think the voice of kelsey grammer totally
worked but i want to see a beast that's actually
part of the team that feels like he's getting to
do all the things that keep the team together i
always felt like beast was the heart of the x-men
that also was incredibly genius and had a crush
on jean grey again soap opera not only is there
the love triangle with wolverine and gene but i
always felt like there was a bit of beast that
loved her maybe that's just the ultimate x-men
talking either way i want someone fully invested
in this character for the long game and there's
an actor that i don't think gets enough love in
any medium as a director as an actor anywhere joel
edgerton is such a force of nature him and warrior
him in the gift which he also directed him and
everything you're always wanting to know more him
in star wars you want to know more about the uncle
that's raising luke than you i ever expected to
he's able to do so much with so little and i think
that beast needs to be able to act his eyeballs
out because he's covered in makeup he needs to be
able to do a lot with a little i think his voice
is great i think his stocky build is great i think
he's got the physicality and the warmth which is
very important if they go younger there's this
guy that looks so much like a young joel edgerton
that i hadn't seen anything of except
for the transformers movies till i saw
a couple of his indies and i was like this guy
that's why he keeps getting cast jack rainer
is incredible when he's not in a giant tent pole
and i think i'd love to see him in a giant temple
getting to show the indie range that he has
so jack rainer or joel edgerton are my beast
i think nightcrawler should be in from the
very beginning i love allen cummings for
trailing x2 but i want to see nightcrawler from
the all-new x-men i want to see him jump right
in from giant seismic number one and i think
he needs to be handsome and swashbuckling
and blue and furry and i want dev patel dev
patel has this confidence this intelligence
this very interesting almost uh shakespearean
movement about him i know that's a weird thing
to say but the way he moves is very in a space
and if you're bamfing around your body presence
is really important and i think dave patel
especially after the green knight showed me
that i want that in this swashbuckling bamfer
and i think dev patel could do a really great
older nightcrawler if they go younger i want
mr heartthrob himself i think he'd look good in
blue furry makeup i think he'd be a great draw
for audiences and i think he's got an elfish
handsomeness i want timothy chalamet as the young
nightcrawler and i think he'd absolutely crush
timothy timmy clementine to be great dude think
about him and doon he comes in he's got like the
the red little harness on he's banffing around
he's got a sword got tail another founding x-men
that is a very important character to the team
because he's the levity he's both the levity in
comedic moments for just throwing out one-liners
but also the levity when things get really dark
that he's able to be the warmth ironically
because he's iceman iceman has been recently
revealed to be an omega level mutant he's one of
the most powerful mutants and he can literally
do what magneto does with magnets but with all
moisture in the air this guy is very powerful
but he's got this comedic sensibility that it's
really important the character that i think john
cho has john cho a lot of people know from like
harold and kumar and things but if you've looked
at his more recent work in things like cowboy
bebop or especially searching this guy is so so
talented while also being comedic and i think
that is so essential for iceman i want to see
the iceman from the comics and i think if they get
an older actor again someone in their 30s that's
john cho they go younger i want someone that is
pure bombast i want someone that is eccentric
i want someone that makes me go like what is this
guy doing a chaos element someone that would be
the team is going through all this stuff but one
guy's keeping us like okay the world hates and
fears them but this guy's fascinating robert sheen
i want robert sheehan from umbrella academy icing
up and being bobby drake and being all sorts of
weird these are very two different casting but i
think that's an example of when the actor ages and
the character ages it changes their dynamics so
jon cho or robert sheen and now for my penultimate
pick i do think this character will be much more
utilized in these rounds of films kitty pride
everyone kitty pride i think in the comics right
now they've used kitty pride as a leader quite
a few times i think we've seen that her power
set is very dynamic and can be very useful and i
especially love her current run of the marauders
books where she's literally a pirate rescuing
mutants that can't make it through krakowa's gates
that's another whole longer conversation but kitty
pride i would love to get her time in the sun if
they go with an older actress i would say alicia
vikander i think she has shown that she can lead
she's charismatic she deserves a franchise to be
honest she's been in all these incredible indies
and tomb raider didn't work out she's available i
think she'd be a very interesting leader of either
the main x-men or a subsective x-men as this world
expands if they go younger i think caitlyn dever
is so charismatic and again another natural
leader and kitty pride's a character that has
a youthfulness to her even as she ages and i'd
love to see the wolverine kitty pride dynamic
like you have in days or future past and other
things so caitlyn dever of book smart i think
has all those attributes if they lean younger for
k prime all right and for my last poll he only
briefly appeared in an x-men movie in the worst of
the x-men movies in my opinion x-men 3 and he's a
founding member of the x-men one of my favorite
actors playing ben foster could not do that
character justice they didn't give him the writing
i want this character written well i want warren
worthington iii to age into the archangel that we
kind of got an apocalypse i want this character
to be the rich playboy that has had everything
he's ever wanted and then literally grew angel
wings and then the world fell apart around him but
he's still got that billionaire status you need
someone that feels almost capitalistically regal
in a negative and positive way you want someone
that feels like they could be a billionaire but
also has the empathy of someone that is literally
an angel but understands helping people i love
michael ely and he's got a presence about a man
he's got this this stunning visage while also
having the acting chops to play this heart of
the character and if they go with an older actor
i think michael ealey would be great if they go
younger i think diego banetta has not had a lot
of opportunity to show his range i think he's
a very talented actor with those flowing locks
and everything else he's got an angelic nature
about him and he's also got a strength while still
being soft enough that he could play the angel and
that's a again a very hard line to walk those are
my two pulses that is gonna do it for today but
i've heard your comments and you all want more
comic recommendations which means the world to
me so let me give you a few comic rex for these
great x-men i would start with giant size x-men
number one now when the x-men were founded it was
a team of five they realized around issue 94 they
needed more people that's when nightcrawler storm
and a bunch of the wave of x-men we know and love
came in i would read giant-sized x-men number one
and also check out jim lee's x-men number one not
uncanny x-men number one x-men number one came
out in 1991 that 90s flavor of x-men inspired
the tv show and i also think the 90s x-men is
going to inspire this team we're going to see
on the big screen and then my more obscure poll is
going to be mutant massacre this was a book that
spread around all of the titles x factor uncanny
x-men x-men it was the first big crossover event
it dealt with the morlocks the marauders and a
lot more seeds were planted eventually planting
seeds for mr sinister which i do think they're
gonna do in the movies i think we're eventually
gonna get mr sinister i think we're gonna get
omega red and a lot of characters we haven't
seen yet gotta plant those seeds and it's great
art by john meter junior mutant masker giant
size x-men number one as well as x-men number one
of my three polls that i think the mcu may pull
from you guys want to see more fan casting if you
want to see me cast chamber banshee monet i got
tons in my head i do think they're gonna expand
out to x factor generation x x-force all sorts
of characters x-force but if you guys want to see
those fan casting as well you can leave a comment
because greg's like koi you just cast 12 x-men i
don't want to see or hear any more of this [__]
they need it times two that's 24 fan cast and i
had three for a few characters that's 25 fan cast
far too much but if you want to see it leave a
comment below thank you for being so welcoming to
my being part of the reject nation i appreciate
each and every one of you go read a comic love
your fellow man that's the x-men are all about
because they're better than the fellow man because
they realize they can help people to get far in
life that's important i love you i'll see you soon